Donc la leçon du jour est : comment braquer une banque,
et il est clair que le grand public a besoin d'être guidé,
parce que le gain moyen d'un braquage de banque
est seulement de 7 500 dollars.
Des novices qui ne connaissent rien
à la falsification des comptes.
Les gens qui savent, bien sûr, dirigent nos plus grandes banques,
et à la dernière recapitalisation,
ils nous ont coûté plus de 11 000 milliards de dollars.
Voici à quoi ressemblent ces milliards.
Il y a combien de zéros ?
Et ils nous ont aussi coûté plus de 10 millions d'emplois.
Alors notre tâche est de nous éduquer
pour que nous puissions comprendre pourquoi ces crises financières arrivent,
de manière récurrente et en s'amplifiant,
et comment nous pouvons les éviter dans le futur.
Et la réponse à ça est
que nous devons arrêter l'épidémie de fraude au contrôle.
La fraude au contrôle est ce qui arrive
quand les gens qui contrôlent,
généralement le directeur général,
une entité apparemment légitime,
l'utilise comme arme pour frauder.
Et c'est ce qui constitue des armes de destruction massive
dans le monde financier.
Ils suivent aussi une stratégie particulière en finance,
parce que l'arme de choix en finance
est la comptabilité,
et il y a une recette pour la fraude au contrôle en comptabilité,
et comment cela arrive.
Et nous avons découvert cette recette
d'une façon assez bizarre sur laquelle je reviendrai dans un moment.
Le premier ingrédient de la recette : croître comme des fous ;
deuxièmement, en faisant ou en achetant des prêts vraiment minables,
mais des prêts qui sont faits à un très haut taux d'intérêt
ou taux de rendement ;
troisièmement, tout en ayant un endettement extrême --
c'est-à-dire beaucoup de dettes comparé à vos fonds propres ;
et quatrièmement, tout en ne fournissant que d'insignifiantes réserves pour pertes
contre les pertes inévitables.
Si vous suivez ces quatre étapes simples,
et n'importe quelle banque peut les suivre,
alors vous êtes mathématiquement certains
que trois choses vont se passer.
La première chose est
que vous allez déclarer des profits bancaires records --
pas seulement élevés, mais records.
Deuxièmement, le directeur général va être immédiatement incroyablement riche
par le système moderne de compensation des cadres dirigeants.
Et troisièmement, plus loin dans l'avenir,
la banque va souffrir des pertes catastrophiques
et fera faillite à moins d'être sauvée financièrement.
Et c'est une indication de la façon
dont on a découvert cette recette,
parce que nous l'avons découverte par un processus d'autopsie.
Pendant la débâcle de l'épargne et des prêts en 1984,
nous avons examiné chaque défaillance,
et nous avons cherché des caractéristiques communes,
et nous avons découvert que cette recette était commune
à chacune de ces fraudes.
En d'autres termes, un légiste pourrait trouver ces choses
parce que c'est une recette fatale
qui va détruire les banques
ainsi que l'économie.
Et cela se révèle être précisement
ce qui aurait pu arrêter cette crise,
celle qui nous a coûté 11 000 milliards de dollars,
rien que dans le secteur des ménages,
qui nous a coûté 10 millions d'emplois,
qui était de loin la crise financière la plus facile
à éviter complètement
si nous avions simplement appris les leçons
des épidémies de fraude au contrôle,
surtout en utilisant cette recette.
Alors voyons cette crise,
et les deux énormes épidémies
de la fraude sur l'émission des prêts qui a conduit à cette crise --
fraude sur l'évaluation et prêts mensongers --
et ce que nous allons voir
en regardant ces deux-là est que
nous avons eu des alertes incroyablement tôt
sur ces fraudes.
Nous avons eu des alertes dont nous aurions pu facilement profiter,
parce qu'au moment de la débâcle sur l'épargne et les prêts,
nous avions compris comment répondre à
et prévenir ces crises.
Et troisièmement, ces alertes étaient sans ambiguïté.
Elles étaient claires sur le fait que ce qui se passait
était une épidémie croissante de la fraude sur les contrôles comptables.
Prenons d'abord la fraude sur l'estimation.
C'est simplement le fait de surcoter la valeur
de la maison qui est donnée en hypothèque
comme garantie pour le prêt.
En 2000,
c'est plus d'un an avant la faillite d'Enron, au fait,
les estimateurs experts honnêtes ont organisé une pétition formelle
suppliant le gouvernement fédéral d'agir,
et l'industrie d'agir,
pour arrêter cette épidémie de fraude sur l'estimation.
Et les estimateurs experts ont expliqué comment ça arrivait,
que les banques demandaient aux estimateurs experts
d'exagérer leur estimation,
et que si les estimateurs experts refusaient de le faire,
elles, les banques, mettraient sur une liste noire
les estimateurs experts honnêtes
et refuseraient de faire appel à eux.
Or, nous avons vu cela dans le passé avec la débâcle de l'épargne et des prêts,
et nous savons que ce type de fraude
peut seulement venir des prêteurs,
et qu'aucun prêteur honnête n'exagèrerait jamais l'estimation,
parce que c'est la plus grande protection contre la perte.
Donc c'était une mise en garde venant incroyablement tôt, en 2000.
C'était quelque chose que nous avions vu dans le passé,
et c'était vraiment sans ambiguïté.
C'était une épidémie de fraude sur les contrôles comptables
menée par les banques.
Qu'en est-il des prêts mensongers ?
Eh bien, cette alerte est en fait venue plus tôt.
La débâcle sur l'épargne et les prêts date basiquement
du début des années 80 jusqu'à 1993,
et au milieu de la bataille contre cette vague
de fraude sur les contrôles comptables,
en 1990, nous avons trouvé qu'un second front
de fraude avait commencé.
Et comme toutes les bonnes fraudes financières en Amérique,
elle a commencé à Orange County, en Californie.
Et il se trouvait que nous étions les régulateurs régionaux pour cela.
Et nos examinateurs nous ont dit
qu'ils émettaient des prêts sans même vérifier
quel était le revenu de l'emprunteur.
C'est de la folie, ça doit mener à des pertes énormes,
et ça n'a de sens que pour les entités engagées
dans ces fraudes aux contrôles comptables.
Et nous avons dit qu'ils avaient absolument raison,
et nous avons évincé ces prêts mensongers
hors du secteur en 1990 et 1991,
mais nous ne pouvions gérer que le secteur
se trouvant sous notre autorité,
c'est-à-dire l'épargne et les prêts,
et donc la plus grande et la plus mauvaise des fraudes,
Long Beach Savings, a volontairement abandonné
sa charte fédérale sur l'épargne et les prêts,
a abandonné la garantie fédérale des dépôts,
s'est convertie pour devenir une banque hypothécaire
dans le seul but d'échapper à notre autorité,
et a changé son nom pour Ameriquest,
et est devenue la plus célèbre
des fraudes sur les prêts mensongers au début,
et en plus,
ils s'en sont délibérément pris aux minorités.
Donc nous étions encore au courant pour cette crise.
Nous l'avions vue avant. Nous l'avions arrêtée avant.
Nous en avions été alertés incroyablement tôt,
et c'était absolument sans ambiguïté
qu'aucun prêteur honnête n'accorderait de prêt de cette façon.
Alors voyons la réaction
du secteur et des autorités de réglementation
et des procureurs à ces signes avant-coureurs clairs
qui auraient pu éviter la crise.
Commençons avec le secteur bancaire.
Le secteur a répondu de 2003 à 2006
en augmentant le nombre de prêts mensongers
de près de 500%.
Il s'agissait des prêts
qui ont dramatiquement gonflé la bulle
et ont produit la crise économique.
Dès 2006, la moitié de tous les prêts dits à risque
étaient aussi des prêts mensongers.
Ils ne sont pas incompatibles, c'est juste qu'ensemble,
ils sont la combinaison la plus toxique
que vous puissiez imaginer.
En 2006, 40% de tous les prêts faits cette année-là,
tous les prêts au logement émis cette année-là, étaient mensongers,
40%.
Et cela en dépit d'une mise en garde
des propres spécialistes anti-fraude du secteur
qui disaient que ces prêts étaient une invitation ouverte
aux fraudeurs,
et qu'ils avaient une fréquence de fraude de 90%,
neuf zéro.
En réponse à cela, le secteur
a d'abord commencé à appeler ces prêts « prêts mensongers »,
ce qui manque de subtilité,
et ensuite, les a augmentés massivement,
et aucune autorité de réglementation gouvernementale n'a jamais
requis ni encouragé aucun prêteur
à accorder un prêt mensonger
ni quiconque à acheter un prêt mensonger,
et cela inclut explicitement Fannie et Freddie.
Cela est venu des prêteurs
à cause de la recette de fraude.
Qu'est-il arrivé à la fraude à l'évaluation ?
Elle aussi s'est étendue remarquablement.
En 2007, quand l'enquête par les experts a été terminée,
90% des experts ont rapporté
qu'ils avaient été victimes de coercition
de la part des prêteurs essayant de les forcer à surcoter une estimation.
En d'autres termes, les deux formes de fraude
sont devenues absolument endémiques et normales,
et c'est ce qui a conduit à la bulle.
Qu'est-il arrivé au secteur gouvernemental ?
Eh bien le gouvernement, comme je vous l'ai dit,
quand nous étions l'autorité de régulation pour l'épargne et les prêts,
nous pouvions seulement nous occuper de notre secteur,
et si les gens abandonnaient leur assurance-dépôt fédérale,
nous ne pouvions rien leur faire.
Le Congrès, cela peut vous paraître invraisemblable,
mais ils ont bien fait quelque chose d'intelligent en 1994,
et ont passé le Home Ownership and Equity Protection Act
qui a donné à la Fed, et seulement à la Réserve Fédérale,
l'autorité explicite, légale, de bannir les prêts mensongers
de chaque prêteur,
qu'ils aient ou non une assurance-dépôt fédérale.
Alors qu'ont fait Ben Bernanke et Alan Greenspan,
en tant que présidents de la Fed,
quand ils ont eu ces alertes
qu'il s'agissait de prêts incroyablement frauduleux
et qu'ils étaient en train d'être vendus au marché secondaire ?
Rappelez-vous, il n'y a pas d'exorciste pour les fraudes.
Une fois qu'un prêt frauduleux commence,
il ne peut qu'être vendu sur le marché secondaire
via plus de fraude,
mentant à propos des rapports et des garanties,
et après ces gens vont produire
des titres de créances hypothécaires et des dérivés exotiques
qui vont aussi être théoriquement garantis
par ces prêts frauduleux.
Donc cette fraude va progresser
à travers tout le système,
va dramatiquement gonfler la bulle, produire un désastre.
Et souvenez-vous, nous en avions l'experience.
Nous avions vu des pertes significatives,
et nous avions l'expérience des autorités régulatrices
pour l'arrêter.
Greenspan et Bernanke ont refusé
d'utiliser l'autorité de l'acte légistatif
pour arrêter les prêts mensongers.
Et c'était une affaire avant tout de dogmatisme.
Ils sont juste horriblement opposés
à toute régulation.
Mais c'est aussi la compétition internationale en laxisme,
la course vers le fond
entre les États-Unis et le Royaume-Uni,
la City de Londres en particulier,
et la City de Londres a gagné cette course vers le fond,
mais ça voulait dire que toutes les régulations de l'Ouest
étaient complètement dégradées
dans cette stupide compétition pour être
celui qui aura les régulations les plus faibles.
Alors c'était la réponse réglementaire.
Qu'en était-il de la réponse des procureurs
après la crise,
après 11 000 milliards de dollars de pertes,
après 10 millions d'emplois perdus,
une crise dans laquelle les pertes et les fraudes
étaient plus de 70 fois plus grandes
que la débâcle de l'épargne et des prêts ?
Dans la débâcle de l'épargne et des prêts,
notre agence qui a régulé l'épargne et les prêts, OTS,
a fait plus de 30 000 poursuites criminelles,
produit plus de 1000 condamnations pour acte délictueux grave
rien que dans des cas désignés comme étant majeurs,
et cela minimise le degré d'établissement des priorités,
parce que nous travaillions avec le FBI
pour créer la liste des 100 fraudes organisées les plus graves,
le pire du pire absolu, dans tout le pays.
Environ 300 crédits immobiliers impliqués,
environ 600 cadres supérieurs.
Pratiquement tous ont été poursuivis.
Nous avions un taux de condamnation de 90%.
C'est le plus grand succès contre
des criminels de l'élite des cols blancs jamais produit,
et c'était grâce à cette compréhension
de la fraude au contrôle
et du mécanisme de comptabilité de la fraude au contrôle.
Faisons un bond dans le temps vers la crise actuelle.
La même agence, Office of Thrift Supervision,
qui était censée réglementer
beaucoup des plus grands émetteurs de prêts mensongers dans le pays,
a fait, même aujourd'hui -- il n'existe plus,
mais jusqu'à l'an dernier,
elle n'avait fait aucune poursuite criminelle.
L'Office of Comptroller of the Currency,
qui est censé réguler les plus grandes banques du pays,
n'a fait aucune poursuite criminelle.
La Fed semble n'avoir fait
aucune poursuite criminelle.
La Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
est assez intelligente pour refuser de répondre à la question.
Sans aucune directive des autorités de réglementation,
le FBI n'a aucune compétence
pour enquêter sur les fraudes complexes.
Ce n'est pas simplement qu'ils ont dû
réinventer la roue
sur la façon de faire ces poursuites judiciaires,
ils ont oublié que la roue existe,
et par conséquent, ils n'ont aucune poursuite,
et bien sûr, aucune condamnation,
pour aucune de ces fraudes de l'élite bancaire,
le genre Wall Street,
qui ont mené à cette crise.
Sans expertise de la part des régulateurs,
le FBI a formé ce qu'il appelle un partenariat
avec la Mortgage Bankers Association en 2007.
La Mortgage Bankers Association
est une association professionnelle des auteurs du crime.
Et la Mortgage Bankers Association
a prévu, ils ont eu l'audace et le succès
d'arnaquer le FBI.
Ils ont créé une soi-disant définition
de la fraude hypothécaire, dans laquelle, devinez quoi,
ses membres sont toujours les victimes
et jamais les responsables.
Et le FBI a tout gobé, l'hameçon, la ligne, le plomb,
la canne, le moulinet, et le bateau dans lequel ils sont arrivés.
Et donc le FBI,
sous la direction du Procureur Général
qui est Africain-Américain
et le Président des USA qui est aussi Africain-Américain,
a adopté la définition de la crise donnée par le Tea Party,
pour qui c'est la première crise vierge sans cause de l'histoire,
conçue sans péché au niveau de la direction.
Et ce sont ces coiffeurs tellement intelligents
qui ont été capable d'escroquer les pauvres et pitoyables banques,
qui manque de sophistication financière.
C'est l'histoire la plus stupide que vous puissiez concevoir,
et donc ils y vont et ils poursuivent les coiffeurs,
et ils laissent les banquiers malhonnêtes complètement tranquilles.
Et donc, pendant que les lions vadrouillent dans le camp,
le FBI chasse les souris.
Que devons-nous faire ?
Que pouvons-nous faire dans tout cela ?
Il nous faut changer le système pervers des schémas d'intéressement
qui produisent ces épidémies récurrentes de fraude sur les contrôles comptables
qui entraînent nos crises.
Donc nous devons d'abord nous débarrasser
de ces institutions systémiquement dangereuses.
Ce sont ces institutions soi-disant trop importantes pour faire faillite.
Nous devons les réduire à tel point que,
dans les cinq prochaines années,
elles ne représentent plus un risque pour le système.
En ce moment, ce sont des bombes à retardement
qui vont causer une crise globale
dès que la prochaine fait faillite --
pas si, mais quand.
La seconde chose que nous devons faire est de réformer complètement
les compensations professionnelles modernes des directions,
qui est ce qu'ils utilisent pour acheter la loyauté des évaluateurs.
Rappelez-vous, ils faisaient pression
sur les évaluateurs via le système de compensation,
essayant de produire ce qu'on appelle la dynamique de Gresham,
dans laquelle une mauvaise éthique chasse la bonne éthique hors du marché.
Et ils ont largement réussi,
et c'est ainsi que la fraude est devenue endémique.
Et la troisième chose que nous devons faire
est de gérer ce que nous appelons les trois D :
déréglementation, désupervision,
et la décriminalisation de fait.
Parce que nous pouvons faire
chacun de ces trois changements, et si nous faisons cela,
nous pouvons réduire radicalement
la fréquence des crises
et leur sévérité.
Ce n'est pas seulement critique pour notre économie.
Vous pouvez voir ce que ces crises font subir aux inégalités
et à notre démocratie.
Elles ont produit un capitalisme de connivence,
à l'américaine,
dans lequel les plus grandes institutions financières
sont les principaux donateurs en argent des deux partis,
et c'est pourquoi,
même après cette crise,
70 fois plus grande que la crise de l'épargne et des prêts,
nous n'avons de réforme significative
dans aucune des trois domaines dont j'ai parlé,
autre que le bannissement des prêts mensongers, ce qui est bien,
mais c'est juste une forme de munition
pour cette arme de fraude.
Il y a beaucoup de types de munition qu'ils peuvent utiliser.
C'est pourquoi nous devons apprendre
ce que les banquiers ont appris :
la recette de la meilleure façon de braquer une banque,
pour que nous puissions arrêter cette recette,
parce que nos législateurs,
qui sont dépendants des contributions politiques,
ne le feront pas d'eux-mêmes.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)